like the Wicked Witch of the West
Antarctica according to the weather
underground Antarctica has experienced
its warmest day ever on Tuesday March
24th with a temperature reading at 63.5
degrees Fahrenheit prior to this day the
highest known recorded temperature on
the continent was 62 point six degrees
Fahrenheit back in the nineteen seventy
six I know I know Antarctica has its
highest temperature ever but it has
nothing to do with climate change
there's nothing that humans are doing
that is making any of this stuff happen
[ __ ] happens that's what Donald Trump at
least is going to tweet when you see
something like this right or with the
people that you know it starts snowing
and they say well there can't be global
warming cuz it's snowing remember there
was that congressman just a couple weeks
in there with the snow because snowball
yeah well snowing outside so he can't be
getting warmer I mean something is
happening to this earth right science
girl yes and the other argument that you
often hear from the Conservative Party
is that there's more ice in Antarctica
there's more ice you guys so at this
couldn't be a global warming issue but
what they fail to distinguish between is
land ice and sea ice and because of
global climate change and because of the
the patterns of the winds from global
climate change we will see from time to
time more sea ice this is what happens
when they're sea ice you take a glass of
water that has ice cubes in it and the
Ice Cube's melt and then let's say that
they freeze again and they melt and they
freeze again and the level of the water
stays the same because its water in
water when the land ice melts it's
[ __ ] catastrophic it falls into the
ocean and the ocean levels rise I'm
suggesting it and it makes Florida
disappear yeah so just to be clear you
know you were very clear but I wanted is
really clear this thing out so when the
land ice melt that water has to go
somewhere all's into the ocean plus
water raises and Florida and New Orleans
and as water as water heats up it
actually expands we've got we've got a
two-fold problem the water itself is
expanding and the water is taking in ice
that's falling off of the land into the
ocean to extend that FIFA sea level rise
even more this is incredibly dangerous
we're starting to see that when the land
gets warm like this
it actually melts the ice from
underneath so it slips off like it's
supposed to be pretty well stuck to the
land but we're seeing these warming
pockets underneath these massive ancient
glaciers and the ice is literally just
sliding into the ocean and as you said
you can look at these renderings these
world map renderings and there's
horrifying California is underwater
Florida's underwater and the thing is we
don't feel it here we don't feel it
because we live in America and the air
conditioner blows nice and cold but if
you go and you visit these low-lying
nations these places like Bangladesh
where people are literally under water
when they weren't five years ago its
climate change is happening right now
yeah ironically we're in a drought in
California but that that's that's a
whole other thing so when you hear
someone explain science like that does
it give you any hope that the people
that don't believe in this stuff and for
some reason don't believe in science
isn't you believe it it's a fact we're
even it or not that's the thing well
that's the thing like the guy who
brought the snow ball on the floor is in
charge of the Science Committee or in
Congress it was like how do you expect
anything to change with bad guys keeper
of the gate yeah he's like I got a
snowball so it's nothing going on out
yeah exactly like that that's the guy in
charge but like when you think about the
people on the right and why they push
back so hard against climate change like
I saw reluctantly I saw Dennis Miller's
Netflix special and he does this joker
goes for punishing III don't know I'm
sadistic and he says if global warming
is real like someone just show me why
it's snowing or why it's cold and the
audience just applause and goes
craziness like that's why the earth is
gonna die because the other half of the
people don't get it they just like so I
why is this a political thing that's the
part I don't get what being a
conservative or being a liberal has
anything to do with science like I don't
understand how this has become like this
political thing we're to be like I'm if
you say I'm running as a Republican I
have to be against science it's actually
crazy well the funny thing is that
environmentalism as you actually look
into the research doesn't seem to be a
progressive specifically a progressive
issue many conservatives are quite
environmentalist in their methods they
just like a different message
we do liberals seem to like a message of
like go green and be good for the planet
and hug each other and and conservatives
are like you're pretty sickening to
thanks but conservatives are like don't
[ __ ] preach to me don't tell me about
my consumer rights and so I think if you
approach it from different angles you
can actually feed into conservative
environmentalism in a smart way we just
haven't had a good you know we haven't
had a good go of it because we as
progressives have horrible PR and we
don't know what the [ __ ] we're doing
when it comes to marketing a message
conservatives are very good at that so I
think the truth of the matter is it's
not that most Republicans are anti
global warming it's that Republican
leaders are in their pockets there's a
specific political agenda here yes and
they're in the pockets of big oil and
big fossil no incentive so is that it
though that why don't they then start
putting some of their resources into
green stuff and just make money with
green like that seems so obvious to me
like if you're not denying the sign
right well then there's plenty of but
but it's gonna be there so don't really
but we're not thinking about the future
we're thinking about the right now and
in my pocket yes that's it Russell fuels
yeah there's a lot of legacy money in
fossil fuels and these pockets go deep
and these relationships go back a very
long time yeah and the old people in
charge of these institutions they don't
want change they want to stick to what
they've been doing until you hit rock
bottom and there's nothing less that's
exactly right meaning you want to
deplete the oil go to bone dry baby
nothing less [ __ ] the way it's always
been progressivism requires discomfort
it requires trying things and seeing
things fail and learning from those
mistakes and pushing past it
conservatism is not about that it's
about maintaining the status quo and
holding on to the way that things were
for as long as you possibly can until it
becomes detrimental and the truth of the
matter is the ship is [ __ ] sinking
right now right and we all love to say
that we're ruining the planet we're
ruining the planet but we sometimes what
we sometimes forget is that you know
Jurassic Park life will find a way the
planet although it will be badly damaged
we'll figure out how to go on without us
what we're doing right now is we're
making the planet unlivable for us
also for a lot of other [ __ ] species
along the way which is a huge bummer but
the truth be told we won't be able to
survive on earth if we continue on the
track that we're continuing on earth
we'll figure it out without us I was
just watching that George Carlin special
and that basically is what he says about
you know you know the earth was here for
billions of years before I you know and
it's gonna be here way after we've had
to leave you know ten of us are gonna
have to leave too i just watched deep
impact hahahaha so you know I want to be
I want to be one of those eight hundred
thousand people yeah anyway what do you
guys think why is science a political
issue I cannot believe that it is in
2015 let us know your thoughts in the
comments right